[Music]
Christian
for
was
you
for
[Music]
Christian
e
for
hello am I up am I on yes yes good
evening welcome to the table it is so
good to see your faces tonight thank you
for making time to be here that's a
conscious choice on your part unless you
were forced to come which I hope wasn't
the case but um sometimes you know
especially Sunday evenings it can be
tough to mobilize to come to church so
thank you for being here your presence
enriches our community you can be
guaranteed of that my name is Karen
Miner and I'm part of the leadership
team here can you believe that Christmas
is is a little over a week
away yeah my goodness where did this
month go um so I don't know what the
holidays hold for you maybe it's Joy
maybe it's uh stress maybe it is a
combination of the two which is very
understandable but I hope that when
you're here you feel that you can be
fully and completely utterly yourself
and know that you were loved exactly as
you are um I hope you feel uh just
welcome I hope this feels like a warm
place kind of homey um whatever H homey
means to you um that's that's our heart
that's what we want uh everybody to feel
when they're here um so welcome
especially if you're new or if you
haven't been here very long um I have a
couple of announcements uh first off we
have a baptism information class
happening tonight immediately after the
service it will be a brief meeeting that
Brett will be uh facilitating uh if you
are interested in baptism uh if you want
to know more about it if you're
wondering why in the world do Christians
even get baptized uh or you're
interested in actually getting baptized
uh then this class is for you by the way
attending the class does not mean you're
committing to being baptized we don't do
that here you're free to come get
information ask any questions that you
have um and so uh we would love for you
to join that again it'll be a very brief
meeting about baptism right after the
service tonight uh the baptisms are
going to happen the Second Sunday in
January I think that's the 14th um so
that's something else to look forward to
at the beginning of the year and
secondly I already alluded to this but
next Sunday is
what not hat Creek almost as good as hat
Creek
almost as good yes it is Christmas
Eve no that was great I love the
participation I love the participation
uh next Sunday is Christmas Eve and we
will be having a beautiful service I
mean just look at the flowers flowers
alone in the tree we're gonna have
candle light um that will be next Sunday
does anybody remember what
time four yes thank you Johnny gold star
for you too uh
four o'clock not five next Sunday so
please please please join us at four
o'clock not five o'clock so if you join
us at five o'clock we'll be saying hello
to you as we all leave and I would hate
for that to happen so uh please be here
4M for a beautiful Christmas Eve service
um it is familyfriendly so kids will be
joining us for the entire Service uh we
will have a nursery available for the
babies um feel free
yes
always Shiloh asked if we're allowed to
wear pajamas yes yes that goes for
adults too wear whatever you're
comfortable wearing that includes
pajamas um good question all right um so
yeah feel free to invite friends family
whoever you like uh they will be welcome
here also um so let's uh let's Center
ourselves um just take some time to
really arrive here set aside whatever
happened before
this set aside whatever is going to
happen later on and just allow yourself
to be here now the present moment is
such a
gift so allow yourself that gift right
now where you are feel free to close
your
eyes take a deep breath if that's
helpful for
you
listen to your
heartbeat take in the
sounds feel the warmth of community
surrounding
you feel what it's like to slow down a
little
bit
[Music]
God thank you for
tonight thank you that we get to be here
together thank you for those who are
joining us
[Music]
online God I pray that each person
hearing my voice would feel your love in
your presence
your goodness your
[Music]
grace and the love of
community God help us
to open our
hearts even though sometimes that's
[Music]
hard
and help us God to know you
more and I pray that every aspect of
tonight would point to you in a way that
is authentic and
true and that through that we would feel
free to be our authentic selves no masks
no
pretenses just real
[Music]
thank you that we can do that
here and I pray for
peace over
individuals over countries over our
[Music]
world and I pray that your love would
envelop Us in this season and meet us
right where we
[Music]
are in Jesus name name
amen amen thank you Karen if you'd like
to join us in stand if you're willing
and able
to we're going to open up with Psalm
116 and I just want to say what an honor
it is to get to gather together every
week and sing songs of remembrance about
what God has done and is doing um it's
about connection with one another so if
you don't know me my is is Josh this is
Joe this is Gary and I just pray that
tonight is an opportunity for all of us
to reenter and if each of us could just
take a moment to remember why you're
here and it's going to be different for
every person
so let's sing
[Music]
this
I love you
Lord for you have delivered
me I love you
Lord you have deliver my
[Music]
soul Fe from stumbling I will walk in
the land of the living my soul from my
feet from stumbling I will in of
Liv sing that
[Music]
again love you
Lord for you have delivered
me and I love you
Lord for you have delivered my soul
death my Fe from stumbling I will in the
of Liv my
souling I will walk in the land of the
living
I Will Bless You Lord For You Heard My
Cry I reach out my hand and you saved my
life I Will Bless You Lord for you heard
my and the god of Heaven turn his to me
I Will Bless You Lord For uning Love for
your gra
anding down from above I Will Bless You
Lord to the very end I will call on you
as I may live and I love you
Lord For You
Del Love You
Lord you have delivered my
soul Fe from stumbling I will walk in
the land of the living my soul from my
feet from stumbling I will walk in the
land of the
[Music]
living
amen all right kids you are
dismissed and we have second through
sixth grade this way and I believe it's
zero to first grade this direction we're
going to combine those two rooms so
young kids this way older kids this
direction we're gonna move into a time
of prayers for the
people and this is a time where we can
pray together as a congregation also
remember those in Our Lives who maybe
aren't here who um we'd like to remember
and lift up their name so there will be
an opportunity towards the end where you
can speak the name of um someone in your
heart but Gary's going to go ahead and
leave that one for
us for the city of saxi Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you the Earth
you have given us and the wisdom and the
will to conserve it we pray to you for
the old and the sick for the Widow and
orphan for the injured and suffering we
pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you for the vulnerable the marginalized
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health
we pray to you Lord we know that you
love us and that you hear us so we lift
these names and situations up to
[Music]
you
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and light healing and hope peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
come te Down the Walls bu every W bu
every w
[Music]
buve sing that
again come Tear Down the Walls bu every
bu every
bu
[Music]
youve heart
every heart
every
heart
Lord I
amus you are faithful father all that
you have is
good you're
[Music]
aous like no you come and break through
to me over and over and over again I
aming my heart to you with open hands
Closer Closer dra me in as the dep of my
heart before you again
over and over and over again I am bring
my
heart
open Closer Closer
dra as the of my heart lay before you
again
Lord I am trusting you are faithful
father
you is
good you're
aous won't you come and break through to
me over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer you drawing me in as
the deps of my heart lay before you
again so come Tear Down the Walls I buil
up every wall I buil every wall I built
up cuz you deserve every piece of my
heart every peace in my heart every
peace in my
heart
[Music]
youve every of my heart every of my
heart
[Music]
myve heart
every
heart
[Music]
how can I
respond how can I
respond to the love that you
have
on
me how can I
respond to the love that you
[Music]
have sing that again how can I
respond
to the love that you
have
on how can I
respond to the love that you have
lavished
on
me I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for you I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have
[Music]
heart
and
every of
me wants to love you like you love
me
Lord every part of
me want to love you like you love
me my Lord
I don't I don't
have I don't
have but I have a heart that beats for
you I have a heart that beats for you I
don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for you I have a heart that
beats for you
I have a heart that beats for you I have
a heart that beats for you I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for you I have a heart that
beats you I have heart that
beats I have a heart that
[Music]
beats
God thank you so much for your
[Music]
presence the mystery of you revealing
yourself to us in the form of
child that tells us
everything everything about your
character
God I pray that we would be able to
[Music]
remember to remember what this season is
about as all the
gifts and all the parties are happening
I pray that we would be able to
remember
God that we would remember that you
came came that you walked with
[Music]
us
am you can be
seated my dear friend Jesse is coming up
to share our message
tonight
for those who don't know Jesse so we met
in seminary and uh Jesse pastored for
many years and um really one of the most
gifted pastors I know like he is um I
mean we all seen him he can preach and
he plays guitar consistently and he's
sort of like and he would do that uh he
was like the on man man at his church
because he would like lead worship and
then he like grab the mic and preach and
do you know everything um but uh yeah
but what I appreciate so much uh
about this guy is um his his heart for
um yes he loves the Lord and that is
true but like he loves he loves you all
and um he just gives he gives so much
like I think in ways people don't even
know or comprehend um giving of his
heart and so um yeah so I just I
appreciate Jesse and uh yeah what he
what he brings to this community so I
encourage you to give him your ear
tonight and um and tune in to what God
might be saying through him so can
youall give him a hand see comes
forth correct oh oh awesome yes so my
name is Jesse and I have all the
answers I don't I've just I really
wanted to say that tonight for some
reason um in fact I have zero answers um
no thank you worship team whoa it was
really special I'm looking for all where
did you all go where there's carry okay
yes and Joe Josh like I wish you guys
knew how much work that takes um it
looks they make it look very easy but it
actually takes a lot of work um yeah so
I'm very glad to be here during the
season of Advent um and for those who
are unfamiliar with Advent it's just the
four-week period leading up to Christmas
you you know that we're that Christians
are celebrating uh and looking forward
to the birth of Jesus you know we have
these fancy candles over here did anyone
else grow up in church lighting these
every week yes this was and how many of
you forgot which candle was supposed to
be which week all the time like this
this happened to me when I was a pastor
all the time I'd be like God is it the
pink one this week I don't I don't know
actually it is the pink one this week
technically I remembered um so yeah
that's that's what Advent is and it you
know it's the time of year that we read
the Christmas story The Narrative of the
birth of Jesus more than pretty much any
other time of year I don't really know
anyone who's like reading that story
throughout the year so we read it this
time of year and I love Bible stories I
love I've always loved them they have
Rich meaning for our lives but here's
the thing there was a point not long ago
when I just
started questioning the Bible stories
that I was reading and I just had this
kind of like lowlevel skepticism that
was growing in me it was I was in
seminary and my mind was being blown by
much smarter people than me and they're
like actually it's this i' be like what
um and and the thing is is that this
story The Chris the Christmas story is a
very cute story right we have little
nativity scenes that have little you
know Shepherds and sheep and an Angel
that's like here's Jesus you know and
it's very cute and warm and cozy and we
read it during Christmas but there is a
part of this story that my skepticism
grabbed on to really really tightly some
years ago and it is that part of the
Christmas story that I really want to
focus on because I have a mic tonight
and that is a powerful feeling so buckle
up
baby um
so nailed the intro let's begin so if um
it's true um it literally says you guys
really want to know it says buckle up
baby in my notes I wrote that
intentionally um so we're going to open
our Bibles either physically
electronically or turn your attention to
the screens we're going to start in The
Gospel according to Matthew chap 2 verse
1 after Jesus was born in Bethlehem in
Juda during the time of King Herod Magi
from the East came to Jerusalem and
asked where is the one who is born King
of the Jews we saw his star and when it
Rose and and when it Rose and have come
to worship him so this thing is
happening and King Herod has heard about
this kid being born and he is really
freaked out you know because kings are
highly insecure people and he I mean he
he is he calls this meeting with all the
religious leaders and he says Hey
where's this kid supposed to be born and
they're like well the scriptures say
Bethlehem he's like awesome and the Magi
come and he calls them saying hey let me
when did this star first appeared
they're like well it appeared at this
time and it was bright so we followed it
here we are and he's like I want you to
go find this kid and let and come back
to me let me know where he's at so I can
also pay my respects which we all know
means he wants to kill him um so picking
up in verse 9 after they had heard the
king they went on their way and the star
they had seen when it Rose went ahead of
them until it stopped over the place
where the child was when they saw the
star they were Overjoyed on coming to
the house they saw the child with his
mother Mary and they bowed down and
worshiped him this is the part of the
story that inspired the song the
Christmas Banger if you
will We Three Kings anybody know the
song We Three Kings of Orient
Are bearing gifts we Traverse AAR for my
whole life I said traveled so far nope
Traverse AAR field and Fountain more and
Mountain following Yonder star
oh star of wonder star of night we're
not going to sing it star star with
Royal Beauty bright Westward leading
still proceeding guide us to thy Perfect
Light beautiful song I'm assuming most
most people have heard it in some form
or fashion it's pretty popular great
song but this is the part of the story
that feels surrounded in mystery and in
my opinion kind of comes out of nowhere
it's just it feels very random in in the
in the story and this is where my
skepticism comes in because what in the
world are these Magi doing traveling so
far to see a kid that has nothing to do
with their
religion like I I I really it hit me one
day that I'm like what what is going on
here and you're telling me that some
sort of star perfectly LED them to
Bethlehem they were just like hey guys
look there's a cool star let's pack up
the posi and
go re really do we really think do we
really think that that's how it went and
and mind you that this star LED them 900
plus miles to Bethlehem and it just like
stopped over the house they're like oh
we're here we made
it the skeptic in me sees this as lazy
storytelling I mean I know any any past
Evangelical people should feel super
uncomfortable with what I just said
because boy do I lazy storytelling in
the gospel yikes
um so it because for
instance it it feels like lazy storying
kind of like Jonah and the whale like
Jonah gets thrown into the water cuz
he's sinful he's about to drown and oo a
whale comes and swallows him spits him
out everything good
convenient convenient a whale was there
kind of like this I can imagine like if
somebody were going to pitch this movie
that all these guys in fancy suits are
sitting at the table and they're like
okay so we know that the Magi need to
get to Bethlehem but how are we going to
get them there does anyone have any
ideas and some guy at the end of the
table's like I have an idea what if go
with me
here they follow a star and some guy's
like
brilliant let's go with that weird it's
just weird to me it's it feels like lazy
storytelling so I because that was where
my heart was I immediately started to
dig in and be like okay I got to figure
this out further study showed me this
firstly these were not three kings I
hope I didn't just ruin somebody's
childhood these um these were not three
kings um no they were called Magi or
Ians um scholarship isn't totally sure
who these people were surprise surprise
they never do but we have a decent idea
of the possibilities right so these Magi
could have been magans men of the zor
strian uh Priestly cast that was a
Persian Prophet um largely associated
with helenistic mind predicting the
future astrology any astrology fans in
here don't raise your hands you'll be in
trouble or they could have more simply
been like
Sorcerers um known for interpreting
dreams or like diplomacy like knowing
wisdom like the wise thing to do and
using magical incantation religious
practices they also more likely traveled
with many more people than just three ah
that ruins the song um actually in
Eastern Christian tradition they they
say 12 that they traveled with 12 people
um but even more likely than that they
traveled with like probably in the 20s
because they had guards they had
servants they had helpers they had
Tagalongs so this was a large group of
people that were traveling that far
right these men were also highly studied
highly studied and were exposed to a lot
of different beliefs and religions at
that time they were definitely
significant pockets of the Jewish people
in Persia in Babylonia at that time
because history you know they went to
they got exiled to Babylon then they
went back to Jerusalem but not everybody
went you know some stayed behind and so
they these wise men these Magi were
absolutely exposed to rabbis Jewish
teachings prophecies um in fact like the
old for instance like the one that I'm
thinking of mostly is the one in numbers
uh a star will come out of Jacob a
scepter will rise out of Israel they
they heard this one they also also know
that they were hearing Old Testament
prophecies it wasn't a secret to that
area we actually know this because there
is a a famous quote by a renowned Roman
historian
suetonius we have really messed up on
names people we' we've lost it those are
so much better um he said this and he
was writing you know historical accounts
around that time he said throughout the
whole of the East there had spread an
old and persistent belief
Destiny had decreed that at that time
men coming forth from Judea would seize
power and rule the
world so this was not like a secret this
was well known throughout the area
everyone uh was was looking for this
this King That was supposed to be born
uh out of
Judea now that doesn't explain the star
though and the star is where my
skepticism is the strongest cuz like did
that really
happen like did it really happen cuz I
know that there's some things that
happen and it's cool but did it really
happen actually it might have um well
and and because like I also back in the
day I wanted to be an astronomer when I
was a kid and then somebody's like you
have to be good at math I'm like well
that's out so um but so I do get really
interested in the planets and the stars
and things so so one of the things was
there was at that time a recorded
conjunction of the planets um that would
have been extremely bright considering
that the night sky was not you know
there wasn't a lot of buildings or
things at that time so it would have
been extremely bright and here's where
it gets really cool are you ready so in
ancient Babylonian astrology Jupiter
represents the primary deity and when
Jupiter came close to Saturn which
represented the Jews inside the
constellation p pces which represented
Palestine the Magi referred to Jupiter
as the star of the king they were
seeking and in association Saturn and
Pisces showed them in which nation the
Jews and where Palestine to look for
him that's pretty darn
cool I don't know if that's really what
brought them there I don't know it could
have been that it also could have been a
supernova that was recorded by Chinese
and Korean astrologers and astronomers
at that time they it happened they we
have recordings of it or it could have
been an angel that would be very in line
with the story right it could it totally
could have been an angel these angels
have been popping up all over the place
in this story already why not could have
been an angel they're all over the place
and they're just like surprising people
and scaring them
um big deep breath I wrote that in my
notes because too much too much studying
too many facts um I even SK skipped a
lot for me it is very easy to get
wrapped up in the possibilities and the
historical context and all that jazz of
like what what it I mean you heard me
like that's a lot I that's a lot of
stuff when the truth is for me that is
not where I find the most meaning and
that's not really where I hear God
speak it's not in those I mean are those
things bad no they are fun and fantastic
absolutely however for today I don't
want to us to get lost in those things
and that is really honestly the beauty
of this church is that we don't have to
get lost in what actually happened we
can look at it in a fresh way so I want
to focus on the symbolism of the star in
this story so to shift our Focus to the
symbolism of the story let's read the
opening words of The Gospel According to
John some of you may even have this
memorized if you want to follow along in
the beginning was the word and the Word
was with God and the Word was God he was
with God in the beginning through him
all things were made without him nothing
was made that has been made in him was
life and that life was the light of all
mankind the light shines on the darkness
and the Darkness has not overcome it and
then skipping a few verses ahead head it
says the True Light that gives light to
everyone was coming into the world he
was in the world and though the world
was made through him the world did not
recognize
him and then later Jesus himself says I
am the light of the world whoever
follows me will never walk in darkness
but will have the light of Life there is
beautiful
symbolism in The Gospel accounts of
light and darkness that really the first
place in the Book of Matthew that that
symbolism comes to fruition is this star
it's the first place that's like boom
light and and I mean and if we look at
it from a literary storytelling point of
view this is a really beautiful moment
in the story in the dark night sky an
unmistakably unique brilliantly bright
star appears in the west and Men of a
complete completely different religion
and culture are so filled with awe and
wonder that they are compelled to begin
a long journey towards this Guiding
Light in the darkness that leads them to
a small house in Bethlehem where they
find a toddler at this point Jesus is a
toddler a toddler who is the true light
of the world and like the star that
guided the Magi to him he will be The
Guiding Light to the world and at his
little feet his little toddler
feet they give him gifts Fit For A King
as they bow and worship
him to me I imagine this moment in this
large group of foreign Priestly men
bowing before this child can you imagine
what Mary and Joseph were
thinking like what are you guys doing in
our
house fancy
clothes
these men who followed a light in the
darkness who led them to a toddler
Jesus this was the symbolism that was
beginning something very powerful in the
story and of course right this symbolism
is powerful powerfully applicable to us
right because just like these Magi we
also seek a light to be guided by do we
not I don't know about you all but there
have been many times lately where I feel
a little lost in the darkness of the
world because boy it has been extremely
apparent
lately like it always
is but especially lately for some reason
it feels very dark and and I too am have
I'm searching and have longed for a
Guiding Light to show me which way to go
to lead me to the place where I belong
and anyone who has heard a sermon before
can easily predict where I'm going with
this and if you can't good because I
need at least one of you to be
surprised and honestly you'd be correct
I am going to encourage us to reorient
ourselves to the Light of Christ that's
it that's where we're going however I do
feel it is important to address a
particular problem that we have right
now for us in this whole light dark
thing going on and that is in our
current cultural
moment Darkness looks a lot more like
light Darkness looks a lot more like
light let me explain back in 2016 when
my family first moved to Texas to help
Brett um I got a job at Lucas Christian
Academy um which is this tiny little
University model School in Lucas Texas
Lucas is this small rural community on
the other side of Wy um very small town
very small town um you know there's a
lot more land the lots have a lot more
space between them you know it's it's
that Vibe it's that Vibe and so we at my
school we were about to get new football
field lights and I was really excited
because that meant we could do night
games it's going to bring more people
out you know as the Student Life
director I'm excited about this
possibility well the people who were
backed up to the field were not excited
about this possibility why because
they're like oh light pollution the
light pollution is going to ruin the
vibe of our little town it's going to
ruin the health of our children it's
going to ruin
everything and I was so annoyed I was so
annoyed at these people because I'm like
guys it is not that bad it's not that
bad like you can have free tickets to
the games it was just it was so
frustrating so it actually launched me
into research as these things normally
do um and I what I found about light
pollution at that time was pretty
astounding and now being a special
education teacher my life revolves
around data so I went back and looked at
updated data um in a recent paper
2023 um this author found that light
pollution of the world's night skies has
increased by as much as 10% a year since
2011 10% a year
here I don't math well but I can
understand that on some level based on
Star counts made by citizen scientists
paraphrasing the authors uh the night
sky would be would brighten by a factor
of about four over the duration of human
childhood strongly reducing the
visibility of stars really in a nutshell
it's just that the visibility of stars
is and ultimately the beauty of the
night sky is rapidly
disintegrating
so ultimately while I was annoyed with
these people I did eventually side with
them I did kind of say actually they
have a really good point here it is
going to really affect this little town
that has no big buildings in it so and
this is my point is in our current
culture the problem isn't Darkness but
it's too much light we have thousands of
stars or guiding lights telling us that
they will lead us to where we need to go
thousands I mean we we could think of
some here um I'm going to sound like an
old Crogan when I say this but social
media advertisements for the next next
big thing uh a new romantic relationship
money alcohol addiction drugs all of
these things act more like a light
promising to guide you to where you want
to go and spiritually speaking these
things become light pollution in our
lives it becomes light pollution
drowning out all the other lights and it
makes it harder and harder to see The
Guiding Light of Christ and this is
actually incredibly harmful to us as
people actually Brett I was when I
brought this uh this idea up to Brett um
he had mentioned something else too and
we see this in the animal kingdom so for
instance moths you you can see even up
here like I was noticing there's moths
and in in bugs up here they are for
millions of years they used the moon to
navigate and then on January 27th of
1880 the year of Our Lord Thomas
Edison patented the light bulb and from
that point on a like thousands and
thousands and thousands of artificial
moons were being
created and I mean talk about a a
life-changing thing for moths
every light is like a little artificial
Moon and then then get this then we
created bug zapping
lights that draw mods and other bugs in
with extremely attractive ultraviolet
light actually you guys go look it up
the ultraviolet light they can't resist
it they can't and so we draw them into
their
deaths gone I know it's kind of funny
but then you think about it you're like
oh that's kind of
dark because it
is and so this is why I say that the
darkness for us you know looks a little
more like light you know this is a sad
and potent image of our current
problem that we have so many artificial
guiding lights just like mobs are just
bouncing off of bulbs thinking that they
have found their thing that's kind of us
we have found some sort of Guiding Light
and we're either just bouncing off bulbs
or being drawn into our deaths by
certain
lights and that is why I say that the
darkness for us looks more like light
but glory be to God in him was life and
that life was the light of all mankind
the light shines on the darkness and the
Darkness has not overcome it amen
so the question is how do we begin to
discern between the lights what is the
real light what is not the real light
what is what is death what is not um so
my mom and my brother and I my mom was a
a drama director at a church remember
when skits were a big thing in churches
when did that end let's bring that back
um she was a drama director at a big
church and and something happened at
this church that actually forced us out
of that community and we actually became
very very much people on The
Fringe and people kind of stopped
talking to us and it was it was really
bad I remember as a kid I was I was
probably oh seven but I remember it
vividly like how people suddenly looked
at us differently and then so we were on
The Fringe we were very sad but then
there was this tiny little Quaker Church
up the road from our house tiny little
Quaker church and they brought us in and
they we they basically they said you are
you are now in our family and we became
what is officially known as adopted
Quakers we were adopted Quakers because
we weren't born into it but they took us
in they adopted us and I that that
church changed the trajectory of my life
forever in a nutshell I'll go very quick
I went to that church which led me to
attend a Quaker College in Kansas which
led me to attend a Quaker founded
Seminary which led me to meet Brett
which led me to move to Texas which led
me to this moment right here that little
church changed my life changed my life
not only oh think yes yay for changed
lives um but also but also the the
Quaker beliefs and interpretation of
scriptures was so in line with my heart
like for instance the most influential
belief that Quakers have for me is that
of the inner light and really like you
could you could simplify it to it's the
indwelling of the holy spirit it's
simply the presence of God um but here's
here's what's unique about it they
believe that it is in every
person not just
Christians every single human despite
their
religion despite anything that could
separate
them they have it the inner light and I
would like and of course you can see how
that would have led me to this community
and led me to what we do here and our
values here we love the Quakers also fun
fact about the Quakers first
denomination to let women
preach love the Quakers the other thing
they say and this is my I love this
Quakers don't say I'll pray for you they
say I'll be holding you in the
light some of my friends hear me say
this to them like I love
this I love this and because in in what
this means for us in the it
I get too excited about Quakers um what
this means for us in the context of this
message is that we don't have to be
discouraged by The Many Lights and how
confusing it could be because the the
Light of Christ is within us so to begin
to discern the difference between the
artificial guiding lights of culture and
the Light of Christ it's through
spiritual disciplines and inner work we
go inward to follow the light not
outward do you see the
difference and so to do this we practice
what Brett and I usually always end up
mentioning in our sermons in some way
spiritual
disciplines slowing down contemplative
prayer Solitude silence they are there
are many ways to practice these things
and Brett has talked about them a lot as
have I pretty much every sermon I've
preached talks about these in some way
you know we bring them up so often
because these are the practices that
draw us closer to Christ and help us
follow that light um and so rather than
like say here's how you practice silence
because I've done that several times I'm
going to share two reframing thoughts
that helped me as I was kind of diving
into practicing these uh spiritual
disciplines um one of those things is I
I believe that one of if not the hardest
aspects of spiritual disciplines is
simply that is all the mental hoop
jumping we have to do to even begin let
alone have a consistent practice right
whether it's you're feeling like you
don't have enough time or there's too
many distractions or maybe you feel like
you just aren't cut out for this um
these practices are vital right and so
there is this quote this book I highly
recommend this author his name is Martin
La um in his book ocean of light he
describes these spiritual disciplines
specifically contemplative prayer as a
process of decluttering one's inner
World here's the quote
think of a bright and spacious room
whose polished wooden floor is covered
with mounds of clutter of whatever sort
the practice of contemplation or silence
Solitude prayer gradually declutters our
minds revealing the brightly polished
floor the radiant core of all that we
did not realize was already
there this metaphor has been so helpful
for me as because h honestly when I'm in
a bad mood the one of the main things
that helps me is I pick an area of my
apartment and I clean it I declutter it
I clean it I organize it and it's like
an instant mood lifter and that is what
spiritual disciplines do for us inwardly
is we are decluttering our space uh
within within our hearts and Minds
another
aspect of practicing spiritual
disciplines that is tough for me is that
I always feel like when I pr the more I
practice them
the worse I am at them like the the more
time I spend in Silence the the harder
it is the more I pray the more I feel
like I sound stupid or like they I
always feel like I am a beginner and I
don't want to be a beginner I want to be
a guru I want to be the master of
spiritual disciplines and people who
would come to me and ask me how to be
like me and I would say it will never
happen because I'm a
master
that mentality though is very
problematic it's very problematic but it
is like think about our world especially
America that is what we do we want to be
the best at everything um but Thomas
Merton who is if you know me my
spiritual father amazing author he
writes this he addresses it perfectly he
says we do not want to be beginners but
let us be convinced of the fact that we
will never be anything else but
beginners all our Liv
can I get an
amen it's so such a relief to realize
like we're always going to be beginners
and there's always going to be like a
challenging aspect to practicing these
spiritual disciplines but that is the
inner work that allows us to recognize
the Light of Christ that is already
present and guiding us so yes Advent is
a time of waiting is a time of
preparation candle
lighting but I also firmly believe it is
a season of reorienting our hearts and
Minds toward Jesus Christ The True Light
of the
World and though we are surrounded by a
barrage of artificial guiding lights may
we the children of God do everything in
our power to follow the guiding line of
Christ so this is the table not of the
church but of the Lord and it is made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow and you who have
failed come because it is the Lord who
invites you it is God's will that those
who want God should meet God here come
to the
table be reminded that we use real wine
here and the dark is real wine the light
is grape juice and there will be
instructions on the
[Music]
screen
for
[Music]
this last song feel free to remain
seated if you like or if you want to
stand that's fine if you want to lay
down that's fine
um we're just G to take a moment as we
close out the service to be in a
contemplative mode before we go out to
the hustle and bustle before we go back
into the world just taking a moment to
think about the words Jesse shared about
the heart of God being
this presence this um a presence unlike
the world says is power a child him
right there's this incredible story in
First Kings 19
and if you read through the Old
Testament it's really just
this this group of these Mystics who are
trying to figure out what is this what
is this life what is this
God in First Kings and there's a story
of one of these great Mystics named
Elijah who wanted to see the presence of
God and it says there was this great
wind that came but God wasn't in the
wind and there's earthquake and God
wasn't in the earthquake and then a huge
fire roared on the mountain but God
wasn't in the
fire and then it says and then there was
a
whisper
that's what the Lord
spoke yes that's that's what this last
song is about is
about us humbly
coming and saying we're hungry for your
presence I don't know about you but I
know I get these times in my life where
I say I need help
so yeah before we get on with the
holidays let's just take a moment to
remember there's another story
[Music]
happening hungry I come to
you for I
know you
sais I am
empty but I
[Music]
know that
again I come to you for I know
you
sis I
[Music]
am
know
not so I
wait for
you so I
wait for you
[Music]
so I
wait for
you so I
you I'm
falling on my
knees
offering
all Jesus your all this heart is
[Music]
living
broken
IR you for your
arms are open
wide I am
wey but I know your touch
Resto so I
for
you so I
wait for you
fall I'm
falling on my
knees
offering All of
Me
Jesus you're all
this
[Music]
I'm
falling on my
[Music]
knees
fing All of
Me Jesus you're
all heart
is
I
IIT for
you so I
wait for
wait for you
SP
[Music]
away
what else in this
life ever
satisfy
like what
else
[Music]
saf
what a great message going into
Christmas week um I hope you take some
time this
week to look for your
light it's
there don't forget we have the baptism
class that's happening right after the
service you can just come up and find
Brett and he'll meet with you again just
a brief information class about
baptism um also if you are new here uh
or would other otherwise like to get in
contact with us uh we have a QR code up
on the screens um that goes to our link
tree which has lots of ways to connect
with us information about our meetups um
and all that good stuff uh we also have
cards uh that are out in the lobby uh
that you can also fill out and just let
us know that you're visiting we would
love to reach out to you this week and
just say thank you and answer any
questions that you might have if you
need prayer or would like somebody to
talk to uh please come find me after the
service I'd love to be there for you
however I can um don't forget Christmas
Eve service 4 p.m. not 5 4 P.M right
here we would love to have you it'll be
a great time to be together um if you're
comfortable doing so please rise to your
feet I'll send you out with a
benediction that was written especially
for this
community which which means it was
written specifically for
you so you are welcome to put your hands
out in a posture to receive you can
close your eyes if you like or just open
your heart to these words that I believe
are true for each and every one of
you you are a child of
God you are a child of God
this is true on your best
day and it's true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in
between
go filled with the assurance that you
are
loved you are worthy and you are
accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
love and grace and compassion and light
to everyone you come in contact with be
blessed have a good night we'll see you
back here next Sunday at 4 pm for
Christmas Eve good
[Music]
night
for
you so I
wait for
[Music]
you
I so I
wait for you
[Music]
you